[Music]
great to see you again this time we'll
be straying away from the usual stuff
that we've come to expect for october so
yeah enough of the spooky stuff for now
and we'll turn around and talk about
love shocking right feels like everyone
needs their dose of love and romance
especially in trying times like these so
for this edition of vinnie tube lists
we'll be going through 10 of the best
romantic anime films in my opinion as a
disclaimer i've decided to go for
standalone anime films here well i know
that there are some great romance anime
films tied to an existing franchise i'd
like to give more focus to these
standalone films maybe we can have a
generalist best anime tie-in films list
somewhere down the line
maybe so for now hit that subscribe
button and let's get the show started
[Music]
let's start off with the shinkai film
five centimeters per second
long distance relationships are
complicated i've never been in one
myself but i can imagine how it feels
being so far away from your loved one
for such a long period of time
at times you struggle to make it work
but most of the time circumstances seem
to tear you apart and make it seem like
you just weren't meant to be together
wow i just painted a pretty pessimistic
picture there didn't i that's exactly
the core premise of the film
five centimeters per second the movie
tells the story of two childhood friends
who tried to keep their relationship
going through life's changes we're
treated to seeing their relationship
develop despite being torn away from
each other in a drama that examines the
harsh realities of having a
long-distance relationship
it's a slow melodrama in the literal
sense of the word and the movie really
has its way with pulling the
heartstrings i really like how
love and relationships get portrayed in
this film and at first i didn't expect
that i'd feel emotions along with these
characters that i've only known for a
little over an hour or two as with any
other shinkai led product the animation
and the background art are just
astounding and are the things to watch
this movie for by themselves
from one renowned film name to another
as we continue on the list with whisper
of the heart
[Music]
there are several things that shizuku
tsukishima likes among them is the hobby
of reading books which is what leads her
to notice that her favorite books are
being checked out by a person named
seiji amassava
naturally curiosity strikes and she
decides to seek the boy out along the
way she encounters a cat named the baron
and finally gets to know seiji in
contrast to the driven boy
shizuku doesn't really have much in mind
for the future will a fated meeting with
the boy cause her to slowly find her
purpose in life now that's quite a
surprise from ghibli if you were to ask
me when we look at it a lot of ghibli
films tend to be whimsical and
fantastical adventures you know
something magical if you were to put it
simply in contrast
whisper of the heart seems to be a lot
more grounded in reality that's not to
say that the fantastical elements are
absent but the realistic dimensions
really do their part in giving the movie
an alternative angle to view things from
pretty much everything else you've come
to expect from sheebly's in this film
and those include detailed art
a moving plot and more intricate stuff
such as psychology and expression that
we've come to like these films for
moving on from the titans of the anime
film industry temporarily we have anthem
of the heart
as our next film
ever feel like just retreating and not
speaking up for the fear of messing up
and ruining everything i certainly did
at several points in my life so if
you're like me and you've gone through
those instances
this next film could be something that
you can relate to as i've already said
anthem of the hearts premise is about
the internal struggle about
expressing yourself if you're someone
who's had as rough of an early childhood
as the self-blaming jun naruse
expressing your honest thoughts can
certainly cause some issues it was so
bad that she grew up bearing a curse
from a fairy egg that prevents her from
speaking up
quite literally worse yet the high
schooler jun gets thrust into a musical
which she strongly rejects until she
hears the singing of schoolmate sakagami
besides the aforementioned themes i can
relate to i also have the pleasure of
watching this film at a premiere
screening
so the film does carry a special place
in my heart now biases aside
i think that the film does a lot of
things well it may not be as dramatic or
romantic as some of the other movies
that we'll be seeing down the line on
this list but it develops its drama
quite nicely and is well paced the
characters are likable
and it also shows the nice concept of
growth marked by the loss of childlike
innocence
and coming face to face with the reality
concerning people around you
i won't say anthem of the heart is a
masterpiece or anything like that but i
honestly think that this film is quite
overlooked
so do yourself a favor and watch this
underrated movie
we've got some more ghibli coming your
way now with castle in the sky
it sometimes feels that love just
emerges from a thrilling adventure
one that goes beyond the borders of what
humans typically experience
adversity builds love and finding that
special person when you're in a pinch
seems to be becoming more and more
common well
in castle in the sky our protagonist
shita finds herself the target of
government agents seeking her amulet a
pirate attack on the ship she's held
captive in
opens the doors to meeting pazu a boy
looking to reach laputa
the legendary castle in the sky together
they decide to embark on a big journey
to reach that castle but it's not
without its troubles the government
agents are still hot on their trail and
they also have a desire to reach la
butter for their own selfish purposes
thus a wild chase and an adventure that
takes you beyond the sky's commences i
don't blame you if you're getting some
serious last
exile vibes with this movie castle in
the sky is the first film produced by
ghibli and you can see a style that
they've somehow deviated from in favor
of the more magical and fantastic tales
that most kids have grown to love
you can clearly see this as the movie
where the studio is still finding its
way
and establishing a foundation for their
future films which i think are mostly
better nonetheless castle in the sky
tells an exciting story of adventure and
romance that i think you should
definitely watch
[Music]
in the bright eyes of a teenager growing
up can be a chore
a drag or whatever unpleasant thing can
be used to describe it you suddenly find
yourself saddled with responsibilities
and seeming pressure from the world to
pick a path to take for the future well
if only you have the ability to travel
through time and fix things it wouldn't
have been that big a problem right now
this all seems to be too good to be true
for makoto who finding herself at a
crossroads in her life
stumbles upon the power to literally
leap through time at first she uses the
powerful mundane things you know like to
avoid getting late getting perfect
grades
or experiencing fun moments again but
who would be satisfied by those
how about altering love confessions and
things like that makoto
soon learns that meddling with the past
can have some far-reaching consequences
and that her leaps are actually limited
as homura can spend an eternity telling
you moving across time is far more
complicated than it seems at first
glance and it's a power that should be
treasured and used responsibly
i know mamuru has sold out most for the
digimon movie in summer wars which are
basically the same film but i digress
what i mean to say is that i have
generally an idea of how his films look
and how they go and i think that the
girl who leapt through time is probably
his best work after wolf children the
premise may be simple and its execution
for the most part is but that's what
hosoda excels at taking something
simple and making the most out of it the
message of the film is simple but the
themes hit hard
especially if you're someone who has
some reservations about the present
and the future
coming up next is weathering with you
also by makoto shinkai
to what length are you willing to go for
love i think that one question is the
main theme tying together the second
shinkai film on our list today
weathering with you in weathering with
you
tokyo finds itself assailed by never
ending reign
this is the city that runaway student
hodaka arrives to
struggling to find a meaning of
sustaining himself hodaka takes on a job
as a member of a news publisher and sets
off to tackle the legend of the sunshine
girl
a legendary person who can temporarily
clear the skies doesn't take too long
for him to find the sunshine girl in the
form of hina amano
a girl who can call out the sun through
prayer things seem to be going well for
the two of them but as fate would have
it
hina is more than what she seems and her
powers come at a hefty price
that will change not only the couple's
lives but the fate of tokyo forever a
fairly recent movie i think that it
wouldn't be inaccurate to call
weathering with you a spiritual
successor to shinkai's other work
your name besides the fact that both are
shinkai works and have the trademark
traits of the movie such as the stunning
visuals
both talk about love that transcends
fate however weathering with you does a
good job of making an alternative angle
at those themes and i clearly recall
that when it first screened
the movie had quite the controversial
reception thanks to the characters
[Music]
resolutions
now remember what i said about jubilee
still building their foundation with
castle in the sky
well here's another castle-related film
and i think that it's at this point that
ghibli has already evolved into the
anime movie
juggernaut that fans love today hal's
moving castle sure gives off that disney
energy that gave miyazaki his nickname
it tells of the titular castle where the
powerful wizard lives in an
object of myth he makes his presence
felt to sophie however this encounter
causes the witch of the waste to lay a
curse on sophie
turning her into an old woman in a bid
to bring her back to her normal self
sophie seeks the power of the wizard and
his companions but hal has more than his
hands full in the background
as the war threatens to erupt and tear
the world apart while the main theme of
the movie is howe's relationship with
sophie the film also has some pacifist
messages embedded in it too there's a
lot of detail and storylines to follow
and while it leads to a narrative that
can seem scattered and out of focus at
times it also leads to the amazing
possibility of the audience finding
something new with
every watch of this movie this film
often gets compared to spirited away and
while i maintain that the former is the
more enjoyable film howl's moving castle
is right up there with the studio's
masterpieces
[Music]
at number three is the third shinkai
work on the list
garden of words
two people feeling lost and
directionless in life come across each
other as they develop a relationship
with each other you see that they learn
to stand up and find a purpose in life a
true tried and tested formula that
several directors and anime studios have
taken a crack at
uniquely enough our stars this time are
two people with a rather big age gap
aspiring shoemaker dekal akizuki spends
his time pursuing his passion in a
garden the boorish monotony of ordinary
life doesn't interest him and this is
where he meets
27 year old yukari yukino a woman who
somehow has the same dilemma as him with
her struggling to fit in with adult
society getting to know each other the
two of them find out that they're able
to help and lift each other's spirits up
by talking and being with each other
however that's not the end to their
problems and the question remains
whether their relationship will be
strong enough to be the true path for
them
to find their inner peace i think the
garden of words could have just been
better with a longer running time it may
just be me but with a little over 40
minutes of running time a romance like
this would fall short in some
developments it's not like this is a
whimsical tale with magic and fantasy
like half of the previous movies on the
list but it's a piece of art which will
pull your heartstrings with impressive
visual expression even with its short
runtime
this movie is definitely an enjoyable
watch for what it is
second place is one hell of a tearjerker
movie hotarubi no mori
at times it seems to be cruel right the
fact that love often comes with clauses
and all these restrictions that put
everything into hard mode you can't do
this you can't do that you have to do
this you have to do that and so on yeah
i know that feeling exactly
intrigued by legends like most young
girls here hotaru loses her way in an
ancient forest
luckily for her she gets saved by a
mysterious masked boy named jin
jin leads her out of the forest and on
the way she finds out that she can't
touch the boy
otherwise he's gonna disappear despite
all the odds the two eventually grow
close together and hotaru ends up
visiting jin every summer however their
relationship gets put to the test once
and for all as the no touch rule starts
becoming tougher to keep for the two of
them hotarubi no mori is a short movie
clocking in at just around 45 minutes
however with the limited time it has
it makes full use of it and comes up
with a romantic movie full of tragedy
and drama i think it's one of the best
tearjerker anime movies out there it
also has
one of the most complete depictions of
forbidden love that i know off the top
of my head it's a joy to watch the two
main characters grow
closer and it certainly made me
emotional to see how the rules threaten
to tear them apart forever
finally we camp off this list with the
last shinkai work on our list
your name
[Music]
just who hasn't heard of one anime movie
that helped anime burst further into
mainstream
receiving almost unanimous acclaim i
think that your name is a shoo-in as an
entry to the list and it's not
unimaginable for it to be at the very
top if not the top three probably one of
the most influential anime movies of the
past years
your name truly deserves all the
accolades and praise for those who've
yet to watch the film it starts off with
being your typical body swap shenanigans
city boy taki and itamori girl mitsuha
somehow obtain the ability to swap
bodies with each other as you expect
comedy ensues as the two use each
other's bodies in order to experience
new things and leave messages of
frustration for the other things
soon come grinding to a halt when the
swapping phenomenon stops leaving daki
to go on a wild chase to look for the
girl that he'd come to know quite well
however the road to itamori
is one filled with shocking revelation
after another and taki soon finds
himself entangled in the webs of a love
that transcends
time what more needs to be said the
movie is pretty much everything that you
want from a film of this genre the
comedy segments work well with the
dramatic parts and as with most shinkai
works like i've already said twice the
art is just breathtaking i personally
enjoyed this movie the most among the
films that i've talked about on this
list and it's largely to do with how
likable the characters are as well as
the suspenseful second act still the
best way to enjoy this film isn't to
just listen to some guy on the internet
talk about it but to experience the
magic yourself
so go watch your name now
funny how that ended up being a shinkai
and jubilee showcase most of the way
isn't it it just goes to show how great
some of these anime personalities are in
crafting stories and leading their team
into amazing products for everyone to
enjoy
if you have any other recommendations
for me make sure to let me know in the
comments section i'm also interested in
knowing what your favorites among the
list entries are and how you would have
ordered things differently as usual i'd
love you to subscribe and be part of the
community to help the vinnie tube team
reach its next milestone take care out
there
stay strong and remain awesome i'll be
seeing you next time with some more
anime goodness